the more recent model of the bread
winner where the man goes out and ears
all the money and the woman stays at
home and does all of the housework for
most women it's fine and probably is
actually better than like the status quo
where women have to still do
disproportionate amounts of child care
and hous work plus going out to work
this is what must called the second
shift that you end up doing two jobs
that's I think worse actually didn't you
say you'd worked it out that you were
doing a full-time job breastfeeding yeah
that's the third shift crazy levels of
work that you have to do which is
obviously joyful meaningful but there
are only so many hours in the day it
isn't feasible unless you have loads of
money available to you to not have a
husband father who goes out and does all
of that and still be as good a mother as
you want to be